[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire alors que la semaine de
quatre jours a déjà été expérimenté en
islande et que l'espagne et le japon
commence à y réfléchir sérieusement en
france seules la cgt et sandrine
rousseau candidate à la primaire
écologiste en ont fait un cheval de
bataille la tendance chez nous et en
plus tôt à travailler plus longtemps
c'est ce qu'a dit le président de la
république emmanuel macron dans son
adresse aux français du 12 juillet
dernier c'est aussi le credo du medef
qui veut que les français travaillent
davantage c'est également l'une des
conséquences parait-il du télétravail on
travaillerait plus tard et plus
longtemps quand on travaille chez de
chez soi alors le temps de travail va
t'il nous permettre de réduire le
chômage ont plutôt réduire le temps de
travail va t'il nous permettre de
réduire le chômage pour en débattre nous
avons invité pierre larrouturou
ingénieur agronome au départ député
européen depuis 2019 et porte-parole de
nouvelles donnes le parti que vous avez
fondé en 2013 vous militez depuis
presque trente ans pour la réduction du
temps de travail vous êtes en france le
père de la semaine de quatre jours une
réforme expérimenté par gilles de robien
à l'époque et sa loi de 1996 tendance à
favoriser l'emploi par l'aménagement du
temps de travail c'en est il un
aspirateur tout cela était balayée par
la loi sur les 35 heures de martine
aubry dont on a fêté les 20 ans l'année
dernière sur ce sujet vous êtes l'auteur
d'einstein avez raison il faut réduire
le temps de travail co écrit avec
dominique méda aux éditions de l'atelier
en 2016 vous pensez toujours qu'il faut
réduire le temps de travail pour lutter
contre le chômage car en outre ou
évidemment je vais essayer de montrer
comment la croissance ne reviendra pas
et comment un des leviers les plus
puissants pour créer des emplois c'est
de passer à la semaine de quatre jours
sans baisse de salaire et avec une
baisse des charges pour l'entreprise
vous avez dit que c'est expérimenté en
espagne au japon il ya déjà 400
d'entreprises en france qui sont passés
à quatre jours si vous mangez des
polices basque yaourt mamie nova du
jambon fleury michon tout ça c'est des
entreprises où tous les salariés sont
passés à quatre jours sans baisse de
salaire et si l'entreprise passe à 4
jours et qu'elle crée au moins 10 pour
son emploi il arrête de payer les
cotisations chômage en 95 vous avez dit
que est une histoire qui vient de loin
le 13 juillet 95 jacques chirac
nouvellement président de la république
va chez brioche pasquier
pourquoi ce qui se fait chez parce
qu'ils marchent très bien les semaine de
quatre jours aussi bien les ouvriers que
les commerciaux le patron tout le monde
était passé à cadiot il avait créé 140
emplois et jacques chirac le 13 juillet
95 dit mais pourquoi se construit je
sais pas qui se défait pas cela ne se
fait pas ailleurs juste air présager des
scribes la parole aux débats à la une du
journal le monde en 95 le rapport
boissonnat rédigé à la demande de
balladur ce n'est pas l'extrême gauche
le rapport boissonnat qui dit qu'il faut
réduire d'au moins 20 % le temps de
travail avec un accès à l'information et
un financement intelligent donc c'est
étonnant mais aujourd'hui le débat
revient et oui c'est pas la baguette
magique mais c'est un bon moyen pour
créer des emplois et peut-être c'est la
meilleure réforme des retraites je vais
essayer de montrer comment à partir des
400 entreprises mamie nova fleury michon
brioche pasquier on estime compris créé
un million six cent mille emplois si on
passait tous à quatre jours donc ça
donne une qualité de vie nouvelle ça
fait moins de burn out c'est l'accès à
la formation et si on crée un million
six cent mille emplois c'est un million
six cent mille personnes qui vont
toucher un salaire et qu'ils vont
cotiser pour les caisses de retraite
donc c'est une bonne idée pour vivre
mieux ceux et celles qui ont un boulot
vont vivre mieux ceux qui attendaient du
boulot vont trouver du travail et la
réforme des retraites au lieu de baisser
leurs ordres retraite comme un terreau
bono le maire on n'aura pas besoin de
baisser des retraites pour avoir un
équilibre de des retraites ferghana
ziari vous êtes analyste en politiques
publiques pour plusieurs think tank ce
délégué général de l'académie libre des
sciences humaines membre de la société
d'économie politique une société savante
fondée en 1842 d'inspiration libérale
elle aussi vous sortirez le 7 octobre
presses de la cité les écologistes
contre la modernité c'est votre premier
essai vous pensez vous que
qu'il faut réduire le temps de travail
pour lutter contre le chômage tout
d'abord je crois qu'il faut rappeler que
l'objectif de réduction du temps de
travail est un objectif qui est tout à
fait légitime et une inspiration qui qui
s'inscrit dans une tendance séculaire
donc plus société s'enrichissent - le
travail en ce sens ces kits un processus
dont il faut se réjouir maintenant je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse défendre la
réduction du temps de travail à travers
le prisme de n'importe quel argument et
notamment la lutte contre le chômage
pour moi est un mauvais argument parce
que c' est un argument qui est quand
même fondé sur une représentation je
crois erronée du marché de l'emploi
c'est ce que les économistes appellent
le sophisme duguay taux fixe on va
développer ça tout à l'heure mais je
pense qu'il ya donc des bons arguments
en faveur de la réduction du temps de
travail mais le chômage en tout cas n'en
est pas un c'est pas en réduisant le
temps de travail par les moyens légaux
que l'on offre aux chômeurs et aux pays
de meilleures conditions de vie c'est au
mieux une conséquence la réduction du
temps de travail de la prospérité d'un
pays c'est pas la cause alors pierre
larrouturou juste au coin
la semaine de 35 heures de martine aubry
l'époque qui va balayer les premières
réformes qui allaient dans le sens de la
semaine 4 de quatre jours en kwassa
s'opposaient vous y étiez opposé elle
elle pouvait pas supporter l'idée de la
semaine des quatre jours il paraît même
qu elle avait toujours refusé de vous
serrer la main dans deux fils à ses
voilà non mais ça va y avoir assez
d'être amélioré voilà pourquoi c'est de
ces deux idées de la réduction du temps
de travail ce sont des l'opposé buda
musique surfer le père de la semaine de
quatre jours et s'éveille depuis 1993
avec michel rocard et d'autre on se bat
voilà mais celui qui a lancé le débat
juste une semaine avant nous c'est
antoine riboud le patron de danone c'est
pas un homme de la gauche de la gauche
de la gauche c'est le patron de bsm
danone un des plus grands industriels
européens qui a dit juste il faut tenir
compte des gains de productivité avec on
a cette courbe est assez impressionnante
le patient peut l'a montré avec les
robots il ya des ordinateurs mais l'art
déco bien que c'est juste vous avez
demandé de la cegid pour éclairer le
débat c'est une autre émission est
intéressante parce qu'on a une heure
donc voilà l'évolution de la
productivité de 1820 à 1990 les offres
des déchets de l'insee on va que avec
les robots avec les ordinateurs avec
l'intelligence qu'on a mis dans la tête
des gens le nombre d'étudiants qui font
des études après le bac en france a été
multiplié par sept donc on produit
beaucoup
beaucoup plus avec un peu moins de
travail c'est pas une théorie économique
aux états unis le calcul vient d'être
fait par l'ancien bras droit de clinton
qui relance le débat aux états unis qui
dit que globalement le volume de
production dans l'industrie américaine a
presque doublé depuis 30 ans et les
vrais chiffres 1 c'est pas du pipeau des
ordinateurs c'est aimer pour produire
presque deux fois plus avec les robots
les ordinateurs l'intelligence des gens
on a besoin de 30 % de travail en moins
ça n'est pas la fin du travail il ya
toujours besoin de travail les émissions
seront pas tout seul il faut des gens à
la technique et des journalistes des
carottes pousse pas tout seul faute des
agriculteurs fodé matin dans tous les
métiers il faut du travail mais moins de
travail donc globalement on produit
presque deux fois plus avec 30% grâce à
royan et les travailleurs américains
sont toujours plus productif que les
travailleurs chinois un chouïa de jute
de juste un chouïa devant nous pas nous
aussi quand vous êtes à hollywood avec
une note de travail b mais globalement
les frais des travailleurs français
aussi sont plus productifs que les
travailleurs même le figaro que vous
citiez le figaro vendredi disait quand
même que la france était un des deux
pays où la productivité la plus
importante est le figaro rappeler je
vais pas tenter à tout mes graphiques le
figaro rappeler qu'on travaille plus en
france qu'en allemagne c'est juste mieux
mon ami michel rocard d'il ya deux
débats dont harry viennent à parler
tranquillement en france et le nucléaire
et le temps de travail on s'engueule
avant d'avoir mis un chiffon sur la
table donc oui bonne nouvelle nous
sommes un pays qui est assez productif
où on a 1000 intelligent dans la tête
des gens dans les machines et ont
produit beaucoup plus donc antoine
riboud en 93 le patron de danone avait
fait travailler toutes ces équipes
pendant six mois pour vérifier que dans
tous les métiers de toutes les filiales
de danone on pouvait passer à 4 jours
avec le financement qu'on propose
si l'entreprise passe à 4 jours et
qu'elle crée des emplois elle arrête au
moins 10 pour son emploi elle arrête de
payer les cotisations chômage il est
antoine riboud est terrifié que c'était
possible pour tous les métiers de tous
les commerciaux et les producteurs les
gens du service des méthodes marketing
et antoine riboud lance le débat et il
avait dit il faut passer à 32 heures
quatre jours sans étape intermédiaire il
insiste il faut y aller sans étape
intermédiaire parce que si on baisse de
deux heures le temps de travail ou de
trois heures ça n'aura pas d'effet on
expérimente avec la loi de robien 400
entreprises qui passe à quatre jours de
façon souple je vais pas vous dire que
le patron travaille exactement comme les
commerces ou les ouvriers mais tout le
monde passe à 4 jours et ça crée des
centaines et des milliers d'emplois
quand même dix sept mille salariés qu'on
en profite et 17 mise les anglais disent
que la preuve du pudding c'est ça se
mange
la preuve de la semaine de quatre jours
c'est que aussi bien des grandes
entreprises comme fleury michon mamie
nova mais dans mon coin des pyrénées si
vous allez à pau pour acheter une
chocolatine une tarte aux fraises ceux
qui font du contrôle de la qualité de la
chocolatine ou de la bio c'est le
laboratoire ça me petit labo qui est
passé aussi à quatre jours donc pas à
bordeaux c'est une entreprise de
charpente métallique annecy c'est
l'entreprise qui fait des logiciels et
tout ce monde est passé en moyenne à 4
jours et à créer des emplois mais
antoine riboud dit il faut passer à 4
jours 32 heures sans étapes
intermédiaires et le problème c'est
qu'avec la deuxième loi aubry celle qui
accorde déjà le choix des 35 heures
qu'il concernait le plus de monde en
fait on pouvait signer un accord à 35
heures est resté à 38 heures dans le
livre quoi encore comme dans les cités
ou dans le score le patron de la toutes
les pme de france dans le figaro disait
j'ai signé un accord pour que la durée
collective passe à 35 heures mais la
durée réelle est resté à 38 heures
trente de façon très légal on pouvait
garder la durée réelle à 38 heures 30 et
si vous gardez la durée réelle à 38
heures 30 évidemment vous ne crée pas
d'emplois sans parler du fait que à
l'hôpital c'est un énorme bazar pourquoi
parce que on avait dit aux infirmières
aux aides soignants vous aurez les 35
heures mais le ministère des finances
pour faire des économies ne voulait pas
ouvrir les écoles d'infirmières on
savait très bien que ce n'est pas aux
vies ou vers les écoles d'infirmiers et
infirmières trois enfants ça va être un
énorme bazar pour être poli mais cela
dit il ya encore plein de personnels
soignants qui disent que je m'étais et
crevant et que si on prend le temps de
se former on pourrait très bien passer à
quatre jours donc je crois qu'il faut
relancer le débat vous l'avez dit en
espagne c'est le gouvernement de pedro
sanchez qui vient de mettre des dizaines
de millions pour expérimenter en
allemagne en belgique au japon on voit
bien que la croissance ne revient pas et
c'est un point qu'au losc ont pourtant
important c'est à dire qu on doit
comprendre que la croissance n'est plus
la solution ou axelrod a sans doute
pensé que s'il ya de la croissance on va
réduire le chômage on voit une lumière
du genre si vous regardez sur les
réseaux sociaux vous pouvez trouver une
vidéo assez rigolote on va raymond barre
keddy la croissance revient pierre
mauroy qui lie la croissance revient
balladur qui dit ça y est la croissance
revient et là bruno le maire nous dit la
croissance revient voilà je sais pas si
on peut faire un zoom et la croissance
en france depuis 50 ans il faut être
très optimiste certains vont dire oui
mais la france est un pays pas assez
libérale un état obèse
le regarder en allemagne ils ont ils
sont décentralisées ils ont une vraie
politique industrielle voilà donc j'ai
apporté la coupe de la croissance en
allemagne voila voila locaux motive
allemande la locomotive allemande je
crois qu'il faut être big le voilà et
comme je suis député européen et
rapporteur général du budget le
parlement m'a donné une grande
responsabilité je suis responsable de
tout le budget pour 2020 tonnes de
l'europe et avant le virus y aller deux
fois par mois à berlin pour négocier
comme d'élèves et la dernière conférence
de presse avant l'arrivée du virus il ya
18 mois avant avant noël du patronat
bundesbank en allemagne jens weidmann
dit de l'allemagne en train de retomber
en récession voilà donc même avec une
politique industrielle ambitieuse même
qu'un accès à la formation meilleur chez
nous il ya plein de choses très bien en
allemagne mais l'allemagne la croissance
ne revient pas donc si on veut
comprendre si on a compris la gravité du
problème du chômage il faut créer des
emplois et les deux leviers les plus
importants c'est un vrai plan climat
avec jean jouzel on propose des
financements pour on peut créer 900
mille emplois on a vu nicolas hulot
quand j'ai fait ma grève de la faim en
novembre pour tenir une taxe sur la
spéculation nicolas hulot est un des
premiers qui nous soutenaient donc si on
a un vrai plan climat on a de l'argent
pour isoler les maisons faire des
transports en commun changer
d'agriculture on peut créer 900 mille
emplois et avec la semaine de quatre
jours de façon souple intelligente avec
le financement qu'on propose on peut
créer un million six cent mille emplois
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est à partir
des 400 entreprises déjà passé quatre
jours donc 900 mille emplois avec un
vrai plan climat un million six avec la
semaine de quatre jours au total on peut
créer deux millions cinq cent mille
emplois si vous créez deux millions cinq
cent mille emplois les caisses de
retraite elles sont en excédent je le
répète la meilleure réforme des
retraites et de créer des emplois de
qualité des emplois bien payés
avec ces deux réformes on peut créer
deux millions cinq cent mille emplois et
ça change tout pour l'intégration des
jeunes ça ne règle pas le problème du
chômage de longue durée mais si on crée
deux millions et demi d'emplois ont peu
à voir partout des territoires zéro
chômeur et lutter contre le chômage
d'exclusion
la parole est à fergane algérie alors
plusieurs remarques que moi j'avoue que
je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous voulez
absolument réduire le ton travail par
des moyens politiques alors même que si
on regarde à travers l'histoire c'est
plutôt un processus qui tend à être
spontanée à mesure que les gains de
productivité augmente vous disiez que le
débat sur le temps de travail date elle
il ya quelques décennies mais en fait
c'est un trêve du débat dans la
philosophie politique occidentale et
bien que déjà des 15-16 thomass mort
fantasme sur l'utopie d'une société où
seuls six heures de travail par jour
suffisent à satisfaire toutes sortes de
besoins donc c'est une aspiration qui
est universel et qui commencent à être
mises en oeuvre à partir de la
révolution industrielle
avec des gains de productivité qui
explose dans toutes les nations
industrialisées et avec du coup une
réduction du temps de travail des
enfants dans un premier temps puis des
adultes il faut rappeler que à la fin du
19e siècle
l'européen moyen de travailler un peu
plus de 3000 heures par an pour s'offrir
péniblement le niveau de vie du 19e
siècle à une époque où le travail
d'enfants étaient la norme et
aujourd'hui on travaille environ 1500
heures chez moi quel moment mais comme
en afrique le 1er mai ce l'anniversaire
des gens qui sont revêtues et parce
qu'il voulait réduire le temps de
travail il voulait une loi pardon ça n'a
jamais été spontanée ça n'a jamais été
spontanée le premier mais en fait le
fait qu'il ya des gens qui étaient qui
se sont fait tuer parce qu'il voulait
une loi qui limitait le travail des
enfants qui voulaient loi qui faisait
seulement dix heures de travail par jour
en 1936 le patronat a expliqué que si on
avait des combats dont juste en 1906 il
a fallu que l'église et la cgt se
mettent ensemble pour obtenir le
dimanche comme jour chômé et dans le
livre comme hong kong ou d'inciter henry
ford le patron des automobiles ford dit
il n'y a qu'en france que le patronat
est aussi au style alerte était il n'y a
qu'en france qu'on dit que si les gens
un jour de vacances qui vont se mettre à
boire le patronat ne voulait même pas
donné le dimanche et maintenant les
congés payés on a la une du figaro les
ouvriers vont partir au bord de la mer
ils ne reviendront pas sur la d écouter
le medef de l'époque on aurait pas de
congés payés dans le tourisme et fo les
secteurs d'activité sanaa en france en
france ça n'a jamais été spontanée 17.5
côté spontané regarder le processus de
réduction alors invaincu mais venons-en
à ce raid et dernier point il met des
exonérations si vous ne voulez pas
baisser les salaires et ne pas abîmer
l'entreprise le patron de flammarion
après avoir publié le livre en effet
michel rocard voulaient passer tous
flammarion en quatre jours et je dit
désolé mais si il n'y a plus la loi de
robien et donc ou bien tu vas devoir
baisser les salaires ou bien tu va
en l'air tu va abîmer dans
l'entreprise donc il faut que la loi
interviennent non pas pour obliger
martine aubry ne voulais pas me serrer
la main pas de critiquer le contenu et
la méthode il s'agit pas d'obliger mais
s'agit de dire que si l'entreprise veut
pas ça quatre jours elle va créer des
emplois donc il y aura moins de dépenses
pour pôle emploi y aura plus de gens qui
vont cotiser pour lesquels de retraite
donc c'est normal qu'on lui mette sur la
table de négociation des aides
financières qui font que c'est possible
sans baisse de salaire l'ancien brûlant
des l'interventions rectif franco sans
tréma je vous parle à l'échelle globale
à l'échelle des pays capitalistes
c'est une tendance qui précède
l'avènement des lois sociales et la loi
sociale n'a pas la capacité de décréter
des gains productivité
sanctionner un état de fait c'est à dire
que la loi sociale elle vient
sanctionner effectivement à une période
où les gains de productivité sont tels
qu'on peut se permettre exactement je
veux des membres de la presse anglaise
productivité qu'on a fait jusque là donc
c'est la célèbre que lui l'intervention
ici du législateur est inutile et
risquent d'être productifs est ce que je
peux terminer si vous voulez quand je
l'aurai être contreproductif dans la
mesure où parfois la loi imposée
standard trop élevés qui ne sont pas
adaptées à toutes les situations je
prends un exemple très simple
aujourd'hui vous prenez par exemple un
ingénieur qui traînent dans
l'informatique et qui gagne je sais pas
moi 60 euros de l'heure alors
effectivement ces individus-là peut se
permettre de ne travailler que vingt
heures par semaine il aura sans doute un
train de vie très satisfaisant mais moi
qui suis un humble travailleur qui n'est
pas la productivité d'un ingénieur de
latex scient vous m'interdisait de
travailler je sais pas moi plus de six
heures par semaine parce que j'ai envie
de sécuriser un train de vie qui
implique je doive travailler 40 heures
par semaine ou plus pour être satisfaits
et bien vous simplement ma pauvre hisser
en m'interdisant de subvenir à mes
besoins davantage donc je ne vois pas
l'intérêt d'une initiation jacobine
autorise autoritaire et uniforme je vais
vous dire la mesure où les gains de
productivité conduisent les travailleurs
spontanément c'est une aspiration petite
finale vers celle là on est réduit paul
mathieu monsieur rendre les il faut il
ne faut pas que m
aujourd'hui et des gains de productivité
on va le supprimer mais ce n'est pas lié
la question du chômage et la question du
temps de travail ce sont deux questions
qui sont différentes comment expliquez
vous dans votre raisonnement qu'un pays
comme la suisse qui a une productivité
supérieure à celle de la france qui
travaille beaucoup plus que la france et
éradiquer le chômage sans même regard
d'or revient quand même qu'on me dise
que ça n'a pas bien et l'air de rien
c'est aux états unis celui qui était le
ministre du travail de bill clinton on
en parle pour avoir le prix nobel
d'économie chômage mais si il le dirait
que collation il explique on aura besoin
dans talent il travaille pendant sa
gardé cette usine en chemin regardez la
photo qui d'ailleurs fait des états des
ovales a autrefois il y aurait eu cinq
ou dix salariés autour de lusine
autrefois dans un studio télé il y
aurait eu trois caméraman des blacks
donc on produit beaucoup plus avec moins
de travail et ça devrait être une bonne
nouvelle tu ne nous le bénin fait et ça
ne se fait jamais du chômage n'a rien à
voir avec cette image juste que vous
avez ici une vision caricaturale du
marché du travail vous considérez le
marché du travail comme une espèce de
gâteaux fixe c'est à dire que dans votre
schéma le travail de l'un et le chômage
de l'autre semaine sauf si tu disais que
théoricien d'économies moi j'ai nous
dire que les étrangers volent le travail
des je suis un homme âgé dire ça en moi
je suis ingénieur agronome au départ je
fais d'économie et je vois juste
j'observe je ne sais pas a priori c'est
je vois juste que dans tous les pays
occidentaux on vous produit deux fois
plusieurs richesses en gros c'était que
oui et je le fais avec mon gros temps je
voulais entendre leur voix pour que
sagan aviary puisque nous expliquer on a
eu huit minutes avant le avant la pause
pour vous effectivement le partage du
temps de travail n'est pas la clé de la
réduction du chômage est ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer sa rapide oui
parce que d'une part ça repose encore
une fois sur une conception erronée du
marché du travail donc je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure on se représente le
marché du travail comme un cas taux fixe
là encore c'est le sait le se gave pas
un bateau qui bouge pas et donc c'est
cette vision était vrai par exemple
alors l'arrivée massive des femmes sur
le marché de l'emploi tout au long du
xixème et du xxème siècle aurait dû
aboutir à une explosion du chômage
masculin évidemment ce n'est pas ce qui
s'est passé parce que le marché du
travail n'est pas un gâteau à chaque
fois que vous avez inventé parce que
schaaf et non dans les pays occidentaux
lorsque les fans sont entrés sur le
marché le travail ça n'a pas abouti à
une hausse du chômage parce que lorsque
l'inter le niveau de quoi je vais
dans votre temps ça n'a pas augmenté le
chômage pas trop stylé au niveau de
consommation a augmenté globalement dans
le hall d'un grand travail est une est
une consigne contre ils sont beaucoup
plus élastique et donc n'est pas un
gâteau fixe pareil si on adhère à votre
conception du marché du travail alors ça
veut dire que l'augmentation de la
démographie à l'échelle mondiale aurait
dû aboutir à une explosion du chômage
évidemment c'est pas ce qui s'est passé
donc dire qu'on va réduire le travail
autoritairement pour réduire le chômage
moi c'est une c'est une effectivement
une contradiction est d'ailleurs une
contraction qui était déjà moqué au 19e
siècle par un économie s'appelait
frédéric bastiat qui en 1846 voulait
justement moquer des propositions de
ceux qui voulaient résorber le chômage
par une réduction du temps de travail il
a écrit un pamphlet appelé la main
gauche main droite il proposait
d'empêcher les ouvriers de travailler
avec la main droite comme ça tout le
monde est moins productif et ainsi on
augmente le le nombre d'emplois rien que
ça absurde et dans la même veine il ya
une histoire que que milton friedman
raconte quand il avait effectué un
voyage en chine ils voient des
travailleurs en train de travailler avec
des pelles et demande au secrétaire du
parti communiste chinois locale mais
pourquoi vous ne leur donnez pas des
machines parce qu'on veut créer des
emplois on veut pas qu'ils tuent le site
de machines dans ce cas là pourquoi vous
n'utilisez pas des cuillères pour créer
encore plus simple envoyez donc
peut-être en effet qu'en remplaçant des
pelles par des cuillères vous créer plus
d'emplois mais vous ne crée pas des
emplois de qualité la création d'emplois
est le seul vrai mais je sois pose pas
de supprimer des robots que je dis si
vous mais n'ont pas demandé de réduire
artificiellement le temps de travail on
vous dit que c'est une aspiration
voulait c'est une aspiration c'est une
aspiration les gens n'ont pas besoin de
votre les propositions éducatives pour
réajuste sont spontanément lui s'il
estime ne sont pas spontanément ou alors
à toi il ya deux salaires la plupart des
gens l'enquète vous avez montré jeu
parce qu'on peut montrer 69% des
français je peux si on peut montrer
langue est sorti la semaine dernière 69%
des français seraient favorables aux 32
heures et je pense que le virus c'est
qu'on a on a en même temps envie d'avoir
un vrai boulot et 2 et qui a pas que le
boulot dans la vie donc je pense que je
pense que beaucoup de gens voudraient un
nouvel équilibre dire le travail c'est
important je suis intéressé je prends
mon pied au boulot mais j'ai aussi une
vie perso j'ai pas envie d'attendre
d'être à la retraite mais pendant non
juste c'est peut-être un détail pour
vous mais les dix sept mille salariés
qui sont passés à quatre jours selon
fait sans baisse de salaire et le patron
était quand même d'accord donc vous êtes
sans doute un très grand théoricien mais
c'est tout bête comme jacques chirac va
chez brioche pasquier le patron de
pasquier qui l'a peut-être pas votre
niveau académique dit voilà j'ai créé
140 emplois grâce à la semaine de quatre
jours sans baisser les salaires et sans
l'abîmer l'entreprise passe l'abbé
l'exonération deux ans plus tard c'est
le bâton de fleury michon qui n'est
pourtant pas un homme de gauche mais qui
me dit vous m'avez convaincu on peut
passer quatre jours sans abîmer
l'entreprise et sans baisser les
salaires et je sens que j'ai une
responsabilité sociale qui l'enfoncent
aux propositions du fait que la loi non
la loi permet de ne pas baisser la loi
permet de dire si vous créez des emplois
y aura moins de gens qui seront payés
parfois l'emploi y aura plus de gens qui
vont avoir un job un salaire qui vont
essayer leurs adverses et bien qu'en
fait on
réal où une partie des impôts et des
charges sociales 50 travailleurs des
libertés pas vraiment s'est pas vraiment
excusé moi mais les libéraux comme vous
ne pas que de la baisse des cotisations
en baie des cochons qui la rend temps la
baisse de cotisations oui oui il ya que
les milliardaires qui gagne en france
dans tous les pays occidentaux mise pour
moi c'est pas drôle l'autre jour j'ai vu
une dame à mulhouse qui dès que le rsa
pour moi le point du chômage la
précarité je rappelle que le chômage
fait quinze mille morts chaque année
l'inserm du camp en tant que tel il ya
15000 personnes qui évidemment fait en
suisse pour être plein emploi sur deux
propositions comment fait-elle je finis
là dessus comme pourquoi les salaires
sont tellement tiré d'air en bas c'est
la peur du chômage qui dans tous les
pays des équilibres la négociation dont
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que vous ne
vouliez pas que je vous oblige à baisser
le temps de travail à baisser votre
salaire ça tombe bien le but est pas
d'obliger qui que ce soit dans toutes
les entreprises qui sont passés à quatre
jours il ya eu des référendum qu'en
général il ya 80% des sites des fraudes
et des salariés qui sont d'accord et ça
se fait je le répète plus lentement sans
aucune baisse de salaire parce qu'au
lieu de mettre des dizaines de milliards
pour payer les conséquences du chômage
on met l'argent sur la table pour les
entreprises en exemple qui vous suit
vous en fais avec une pelle d'emploi pas
de baisser les salaires et les gets
cueilli une exagération que l'état en
gros soit complice la chanson des
créations d'emplois la différence est ce
qu'on a fait depuis 40 ans à la demande
des libéraux on a fait plein de baisse
de cotisations qui appauvrit la sécu
quand enregisté milliardaire là il ya
des baisses de l'engagement n'a pas
d'assurer c'est en france faut arrêter
si on crée des emplois du temps travail
et baisse des cotisations aussi à des
créatures n'en avez pas répondu à ma
question comment vous expliquez que dans
des pays voisins on est au plein emploi
sans pour autant appliquer vos
propositions c'est bien qu'ils aient des
facteurs il ya le facteur qui crée du
chômage qui n'ont absolument rien à voir
et la durée du temps de travail est ce
que la législation sociale française ne
serait pas une différence entre certains
pays occidentaux plus libéraux que la
france avec un pays que vous adorez les
états unis quelle est la durée moyenne
du temps de travail aux etats-unis pour
choquer un job 1600 il me semble 33,7
heures par semaine par où c'est le livre
blanc ma maison blanche des états unis
le taux d'activité s'effondre et de plus
en plus de gens qui ne sont même plus
comptés comme chômeurs parce qu'ils sont
découragés c'est les chiffres de la
maison blanche le taux d'activité
s'effondre et parmi ceux et celles qui
ont encore du boulot il ya tellement de
petits boulots que tu répètes pour ceux
qui ont du boulot sans compter les
chômeurs la durée moyenne est à 33 eur 7
donc il n'y a plus aucun pays où on est
en situation de plein emploi si le plein
en passer tous ceux qui le veulent
peuvent travailler et chante à 40 heures
dans tous les pays un certain partage du
travail en allemagne les chiffres donnés
au bundestag il ya trois mois par le
ministre à paille c'est qu'il ya 6
millions également que des boulots à 450
euros 6 millions et demi dans 4 millions
d'onces et le sale boulot partout il ya
un certain partage du travail dont il ya
quelque chose de ta part c est ce que
c'est la loi du marché qui réparti le
travail beaucoup en francs ou beaucoup
avec le risque de burn out pour ceux qui
sont à temps plein et des millions de
chômeurs qui sont à zéro à par semaine
ou est ce qu'on est capable de négocier
non pas imposé mais négocier un partage
du travail plus équilibré sans baisse de
salaire et ça permet de créer
massivement des emplois ça permet
l'accès à la formation soit il le jouera
salariés dans une pme qui dit ça fait 20
ans que je suis dans la même pme j'ai
jamais temps de me former tandis que
l'idée même si le patron ait pas
d'accord si je passe à 4 jours j'aurai
un jour par semaine pour me former donc
on dit pas que c'est la baguette magique
mais une réforme qui peut améliorer la
qualité de vie des gens et créé un
million six cent mille emplois et qui a
déjà été testé dans 400 entreprises même
raymond barre raymond barre nous disait
avant de nous quitter raymond banda vd
pour faire passer la loi de robien aisés
qui avait déjà assez d'expérience
réussie pour qu'on accélère ça ne
voulait pas dire imposer mais qu'on
accélère le mouvement
non je pense qu'encore une fois si on
veut résorber le chômage il faut avoir
la lucidité de l'imputer aux bons
facteurs en france qui sont les chômeurs
alors ça c'est très simple on regarde
les chiffres de l'insee on sait que les
chômeurs aujourd'hui sont les peu
qualifiés et malheureusement sont ceux
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'expérience de
qualification ou de gentils sont jeunes
qui ont décroché à l'école et on sait
très bien ce que l'on connaît très bien
la législation qui exclut les peu
qualifiés du marché de l'emploi ça ça
fait un siècle et demi que les
économistes comme en tête et
l'irritation ça s'appelle le salaire
minimum c'est-à-dire que dès lors que
vous fixé un prix plancher qui est au
dessus de la productivité d'un
travailleur et bien il devient tout
simplement inemployables et c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui
bon nombre de personnes peu qualifiées
n'ont pas d'emploi mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec peut-être qu'on le travail
trop la preuve c'est qu'il ya des pays
qui travaillent plus que nous et qui
sont au plein emploi comme la suisse que
monsieur larrouturou veut ne veut
complètement évité puisque n'a pas
répondu à ma question est d'ailleurs ce
qu'est ça ce qui est intéressant on va
faire une pause ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quelque part on admet de plus
en plus le diagnostic que je pose parce
que de plus en plus en france on fait
l'apologie de l'apprentissage à
l'apprentissage qu'est ce que c'est
c'est précisément une manière détournée
de déroger aux minima sociaux qui
aujourd'hui freine l'employabilité des
dépôts qualifié s'il revient tout
simplement à admettre que c'est bien
notre législation sociale qui crée du
projet y compris quand un jeune
d'ailleurs et on y reviendra plus à
l'aise vous tous les lieux et mis au
vélo c'est notre législation sociale et
millions de porcs et les millions des
dizaines de millions de petits boulots
aux états unis ça notre législation
sociale et géniaux si on fait une pause
on revient dans deux minutes
[Musique]
à
combien s'élève la facture du quoi qu'il
en coûte comment on va se mettre en
place le sur mesure ce n'est pas une
fois qu'on a dépensé des milliards des
centaines de milliards à arroser tout le
monde et à faire tenir des gens qui
n'auraient jamais dû tenir que
maintenant on va pouvoir se vanter de
faire un peu de sur mesure toute la
question c'est ne pas refaire
aujourd'hui l'erreur de 2011 qui avait
été d'enlever les mesures de soutien à
l'économie après la crise de 2008
beaucoup trop tôt ce qui avait cassé la
dynamique économique de la reprise la
déclaration de bruno le maire il sait
très bien que le jo il arrête c'est fini
vous aurez des sociétés qui feront
failli à ce qu'on leur demandera de
rembourser quelque chose qu'elles ne
peuvent pas rembourser elle en était
bien incapable déjà avant de s'endetter
et aujourd'hui elles ne pourront pas
c'est les chaises musicales si vous
voulez y aura pas assez de chaises pour
tout le monde
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terroriste de l'est ce que
vous êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon on savait que les
talibans étaient en train de revenir sur
le terrain depuis déjà des années ce qui
a été balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans
c'est al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001
et al qaïda est taliban ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables comment va
vivre le peuple afghan dans les semaines
qui viennent on va assister à un
raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument sans
précédent y va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident que la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre
devoir moral que de venir en aide à ce
peuple qui a souffert tant par le passé
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la réduction du
temps de travail avec pierre larrouturou
que je présente toujours comme le père
de la semaine de quatre jours et
ferghana ziari qui est un délice tant en
politique publique ferghana ziari si ça
n'est pas le temps de travail et sa
réduction quelles seraient les mâts
kahnisme pour vous qui pourrait
favoriser la réduction du chômage la
réduction du chômage je pense qu'elle
nécessite en effet une plus grande
ouverture du marché de l'emploi une
davantage une libéralisation du marché
de l'emploi maintenant la réduction du
temps de travail encore une fois je le
rappelle je ne suis absolument pas
opposé à partir du moment que l'on
comprend que c'est c'est moins la cause
que la conséquence des prospérité
société moderne c'est à dire que ce qui
a favorisé la réduction du temps
travaillé ces dernières décennies ce
dernier siècle en occident c'est la
croissance économique c'est les gains de
productivité c'est l'accumulation
d'épargné de capitaux c'est le progrès
technique et ce sont ces processus là je
crois qu'il faut libérer si on aspire à
réduire le temps de travail d'un pays
sans pour autant porter atteinte à son
niveau dit parce que si un niveau de
productivité constants ont réduit le
temps de travail des gens dont on va
simplement les appauvrir ou bien
renchérir le coût de la vie exactement
comme ça c'était passé sous le front
populaire en 1936 c'est à dire qu'on
avait une réduction du temps de travail
mais qui a été très mal absorbée parce
qu'on avait des canes productivité qui
n'était pas très bon et donc à l'époque
les syndicats avait même accusé le
patronat de saboter la réforme du front
populaire tout simplement parce que le
la réduction du temps de travail c'est
être couplée à une augmentation du coût
de la vie parce que il n'y avait pas les
gains de productivité qui correspondait
à un mollet la semaine de 35 heures ce
qu'on a aussi reproché à la semaine de
35 heures d'où l'importance sur le fait
que je suis encore une fois que c'est là
le temps de travail la réduction du
temps travaillé bien une conséquence de
la croissance économique et que si on
veut réduire le travail c'est bien la
croissance économique qu'il faut libérer
en france et ne pas sombrer dans le
fatalisme que monsieur larrouturou ici
mais met en oeuvre en rappelant que les
le potentiel de croissance économique en
france il est là simplement
effectivement nous sommes un pays qui
met en place de nombreux freins il faut
le dire des freins réglementaires
fiscaux qui font qu'on a une économie
qui qui qui tourne beaucoup lentement en
tout cas que son que qu'elle pourrait le
faire si on avait en tout cas une
société législation beaucoup plus
ouverte libéral et regain d'intérêt en
moyenne la croissance elles augmentent
de 1,5 pour cent par an sauf dans les
périodes de rabat joir pire c'est encore
pire mais vous en question hors période
de rattrapage laquelle la croissance des
commandes et des périodes si vous prenez
la fin du 19e siècle au début du 20e
siècle où une bonne parmi les trente
glorieuses des périodes de croissance
extrêmement forte le phénomène de
réduction de la croissance économique en
tout cas du rythme de la croissance
safina mène qui est très très récent et
d'ailleurs qui est limitée à certains
pays pas tous les pays connaît cette
tendance je prends le temps de la france
par exemple entre 2000 et 2010 9 en
france on a connu une croissance
économique du pib par habitant de 13% en
france 13% contre 39% chez nos voisins
suisses contre 35% chez nos voisins
allemands et je n'ai pris que trois pays
au hasard donc voyez bien que il ya
quand même une spécificité française et
je crois qu'on serait malavisé d'être
franco centre et en oubliant que dans
d'autres pays avec des institutions
différentes
on a une croissance économique plus
forte tout simplement même si elle n'est
pas aussi élevé qu'on pourrait le le
vouloir si elle a ou devront donc je
leur montre plus lentement voilà
l'évolution de la croissance en
allemagne depuis 50 ans voilà les
salades et à 0,9 pendant une décennie
ces moyennes alors il ya des années à
1,5 et puis elle est née à 0,3 mais
c'est peut-être bien sûr on prend du
recul 0,9 de croissance en moyenne et
pourquoi et je le répète le patronat
bundesbank qui est pas vraiment de ma
famille politique d'il ya 18 mois juste
avant à moi comme le virus arrive
l'allemagne est en train de retomber en
récession et comment depuis dix ans en
allemagne à une croissance un peu plus
forte que le reste de l'europe et n'est
pas tombée dans la récession c'est pas
s'ils ont accueilli un million cinq cent
mille réfugiés syriens ça va énerver les
amis de madame le pen mais la vérité
vous voyez l'allemagne et à 0.4 0,4 de
croissance et c'est quand on accueille
un million cinq cent mille personnes
d'abord pour des raisons d'humanité et
de dignité mais ça fait de l'énergie
carrés dans le pays c'est des enfants il
faut leur accès à l'école il faut
construire donc c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est destatis qui est l'équivalent de
l'insee en allemagne à berlin et qui dit
s'il n'y avait pas eu les un million
cinq cent mille réfugiés syriens nous
étions à 0.4 alors qu on était quand
même tiré comme la suite sous d'autre
part les exportations vers les états
unis et sur les états unis puisque
pendant la pause vous expliquer qu'il y
avait un pays qui avait une croissance
plus forte justin plusieurs la
nouvelle-zélande l'australie je signale
aux jeunes sont pas des 0,7 le
chargement est un exemple j'étais
étudiant à sciences po m'expliquer que
jal le japon allait nous bouffer tout
cru à les dominer l'économie mondiale
j'applique la bulle a éclaté ils ont 0
7% de croissance moyen de la commande
dans le c d e qui ne correspondent pas à
bukavu santé sans doute mais le moteur
ce qui tire et comment vous expliquez ça
oui bah si un mot numérique qui abrite
un dj est très dynamique et lyonnais ne
le sont pas je l'expliqué un moteur qui
tirent la croissance mondiale c'est des
états unis dont vous êtes vous avez dit
pendant la pause que c'était un exemple
à vos yeux voilà la dette totale des
états unis depuis l'arrivée de ronald
reagan et le pays peuvent être que
l'économie peut exploser n'importe quand
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est ya trois
ans on les oublie avec le virus à la une
des échos qui n'est pas un journal
d'extrême gauche le fmi redoute une
nouvelle crise mondiale la phrase qui
était repris en gros dans les échos
d'après le fmi la prochaine crise
pourrait être dix fois plus grave que
celle de 2008 voilà c'est parce que
quand vous avez besoin pour avoir un peu
de croissance il ya de plus en plus de
précaires aux états unis je les
montrerai de des millions d'hommes et de
femmes qui n'ont pas de quoi vivre qui
sont dans la rue ou qui ont des bouleaux
merdique à 600 dollars et donc sonné
pousse à s'endetter on les pousse à
s'endetter voyez cette courbe tant qu'on
tenait bon sur roosevelt je suis un
parti s'appelle nouvelle donne jusqu'à
l'arrivée de ronald reagan il n'y a eu
aucune crise économique et pas besoin de
dette ni privé ni public et avec les
libéraux on baisse les salaires ce que
j'ai montré on pousse les gens à
s'endetter en urgente a pas eu
d'augmentation mais tu peux acheter une
voiture on va te prêter l'argent on
baisse les impôts sur les plus riches
dont café la dette publique c'est
vraiment très clair c'est les chiffres
de la réserve fédérale jusqu'à l'arrivée
de ronald reagan un système équilibré
depuis l'arrivée de ronald reagan et
elie vous amis les libéraux donc la
croissance est un peu plus forte mais
d'après le fmi elle peut péter n'importe
quand une crise dix fois plus grave que
2008 est donc paradoxalement le virus a
provoqué des dégâts humains terrible
mais avec tous les plans de relance on a
mis des centaines de milliards et le les
centaines de milliers d'idées les
milliers de milliards ont relancé la
machine mais dans deux ou trois ans la
crise que le fmi nous annoncer paris
vais donc miser sur la croissance n'est
vraiment pas possible je le répète ce
n'est pas sérieux on aura peut-être
qu'on n'a pas à voir une année pour ino
le maire est content passes et 1 rebond
oui tous ceux qui ont peu d'argent on va
au restaurant on est content de
retourner au resto mais ça suffit pas
pour faire un point une société après
donc je le redis les deux leviers pour
livrer d'entre vous c'est agir pour le
climat et avoir un financement du temps
de travail et quand vous avez dit que
l'art la réduction du temps de travail
était une conséquence des gains de
productivité est-ce qu'on peut montrer
une dernière fois la courbe des gains de
productivité que vous avez montré on a
fait depuis 40 ans dhr des gains de
productivité colossaux depuis 1975 en
gros la ksa l'ordinaire il ya une double
révolution des ordinateurs partout voilà
sept merci beaucoup à la régie cette
coupe est vraiment très impressionnante
vous l'avez dire en début de votre
exposé que la question du temps de
travail d'un mouvement historique et on
a divisé par trois le temps de travail
entre 1820 et 1970 le on a interdit le
travail des enfants on est passé de 7
jours à 6 6 jours à 5 voilà mais on a
mis des congés payés on a fait des
journées de 10 heures et 18 heures donc
en gros alors qu'il n'y avait pas
tellement de gains de productivité on a
divisé par trois le temps de travail
donc là et depuis entre 1820 et 1970 et
voiliers et en 1905 juste riel oui mais
pas dans wii mais pendant oui mais c'est
jusqu'à l'échelle ce qu'on vit depuis 40
ans avec une double révolution les
ordinateurs et les machines et puis là
le fait qu'en france on a multiplié par
sept le nombre d'étudiants qui vont
faire des études à l'université après le
bac cette double révolution c'est qu'on
a fait des gains de productivité de
géant depuis 1975 or depuis
soixante-quinze le temps de travail pour
un salarié attentat n'a quasiment pas
baissé j'ai regardé hier pour préparer
l'émission les chiffres de l'insee
aujourd'hui en france un homme ou une
femme qui est à temps plein est à 39
1h39 une heure c'est la durée réelle
aujourd'hui pour un temps plein en
france c'est quasiment la même chose
qu'en 1975 dont le niveau de vie n'est
pas libre non mais le vent la mer est
bizarre
il faut aussi
le niveau de vie n'a pas augmenté
rien du tout je dis qu'on est juste
beaucoup m'ont plus riches mais qu'il ya
cinq millions de chômeurs sans compter
ceux qui ont le plus compté au chômage
parce qu'ils sont au rsa c'est aussi
juste les chiffres de pôle emploi juste
et quand vous dites je retourne votre
argument quand vous dites que la rtt la
réunion est temps de travail est un
mouvement historique et que c'est la
suite de gains de productivité qu'on
doit mieux répartir et bien se trouve
plus depuis 1975 depuis plus de 50 ans
depuis 45 ans on a fait des gains de
productivité de géant et on n'a
quasiment pas changé la définition du
temps de travail normale qui est
toujours à 39 heures là d'après l'insee
travail annuel a quand même baissé c'est
dire qu'au début des 70
heures annuelles près de 1500
aujourd'hui et aux costa quand même
quant à changer de vie adulte sont
indiqués à 5 millions de chômeurs et
qu'on se demande comment faire face à ce
drame où le chômage je vous ai ri j'ai
répondu je vous ai parlé du droit du
travail faisait parler du salaire
minimum et là dessus vous ne devez pas
mais je voulais juste que les pays qui
ont mis en place vos politiques
libérales ont quand même un niveau de la
précarité je vais pas rater le niveau de
précarité aux états unis a tellement de
petits boulots que la durée moyenne
réelle nationale et 0,33 à les petits
boulots peu qualifiés c'est peut-être
mieux qu'être au chômage complet ne pas
avoir de perspectives d'ascension
sociale ça c'est moi j'ai été un
travailleurs peu qualifiés si j'avais dû
être au chômage ne pas accepter des
petits boulots merdique au début pardon
pour l'expression je n'aurais peut-être
pas été ici devant vous parce que c'est
ce qui m'a permis de mettre le pied à
l'étrier ok pour aussi une retombée
devant exactement à 6 et auquel pendant
6 et le pied à l'étrier mais voit ses
précieux lui et sa scène germanique chez
dit ça ça n'a pas l'air il je dis qu'en
allemagne l'apprentissage était une très
bonne idée julliard est autre le smic
parce que là on atteint messi parce que
les l'apprentissage d'un moyen
d'effectivement de contourner ces minima
sociaux non à ceux ci pour ne citer que
je pense que chaque homme et chaque
femme doit vivre dignement et que par
contre sont en apprentissage on doit
avoir un système qui vous permet d'avoir
un revenu mais que vous payez pas eu lui
l'entreprise ne paye pas le coût complet
et c'est john qui existe en allemagne
qu'isidore vous admettez que la
législation sociale française nuit à
l'employabilité pas de vivre de tennis
mais pas les départs il ya bien des
dispositifs simplement moi je ne crois
pas qu'il ait une baguette magique je
crois pas que ça jute l'apprentissage ou
la baisse des cotisations je ne crois
pas la bague à l'image est magnifique ça
j'ai tout pardon et je tremble
indépendant dans les pays germaniques
l'apprentissage est une assise je
réponds parce qu'il sait millions
sachant d'où personne qui ont que 450
euros par mois mais c'est les chiffres 6
millions 5 et france ô combien et des
battants pérenne si ses joueurs pendant
que ça prenne jusqu'à devenir qui a
quand même une mobilité sociale entre au
début des apprentis qui effectivement en
allemagne récemment y compris le taux le
taux de pauvreté chez les retraités qui
augmente passé déjà coaché notre pays
n'est pas mieux loti c'est à dire que je
vous parlais d'un pays qui est très
imparfait mais je vous dis que l'autre
est encore nécessaire
de négociations sous les voûtes des
négociations je vous dis pas que c'est
génial ce qui se passe en france
aujourd'hui je voulais vous emmener du
côté du télétravail
parce que
où il s'est installé pendant le pendant
le confinement il a perduré aujourd'hui
il a l'air plus faible mais en même
temps on voit bien que bon nombre
d'entreprises n'est pas seulement en
france se sont faits à l'idée on a même
commencé à réduire les surfaces avec les
problèmes que ça pourrait poser
d'ailleurs parce que je les travaille ça
a des conséquences
mais quand pensez-vous l'un comme
l'autre et quelle influence cela peut
avoir en bien comme en mal sur
l'induction du temps de travail ou la
lutte contre le chômage
ou les commencer je pense que le virus
nous a fait évoluer dans notre rapport
au travail et que le fait effectivement
d'abord le virus nous a foutu un coup on
s'est rendu compte qu'on était tous
mortels que nos sociétés étaient
fragiles que ceux qui avaient prévenu
qu'une épidémie était possible on les
prenait pour des charlots et flamands il
ya bien eu une épidémie c'est comme en
2005 quand j'annonçais une crise
financière dominique strauss kahn
expliqué que je m'inquiétais pour rien
qu'ils évoquent un risque de crise donc
ce qui alerte sur un danger on les prend
toujours pour des charlots et donc ça
nous amène être un peu plus prudent et
accepter l'idée qu'on est en dessous
était fragile et chacun de nous je pense
à nous fait bouger sur notre rapport au
travail et qu'on on est bien quand aussi
con à la maison avec les gens qu'on aime
et en même temps je pense qu'on est bien
au travail je veux y compris je vois
autour de moi des gens qui disent
c'était bien télétravail mais c'est
quand même utile d'être deux jours par
semaine ou trois jours par semaine avec
les autres collègues au boulot parce
qu'on a besoin de se replonger d'être en
réunion d'être en interaction avec les
autres y compris d'ailleurs quand on est
passé à quatre jours et des entreprises
au début qui laissait des salariés
complètement libres de choisir leurs
journées de rtt qu'au bout d'un moment
c'était le bazar et on a dit le mardi et
le jeudi tout le monde d'être là parce
qu'il ya un minimum de coordination qui
ai besoin donc je pense que le virus
comme l'anc est que qui a été publiée
une semaine qui dit que 69% des français
69 % des français sont favorables à la
semaine de quatre jours c'est un chiffre
plus important qu'il ya deux ans où
quatre ans donc je pense que en même
temps le travail est fondamental jeu
pour partie pour gagner ma vie
correctement pour travailler avec
d'autres pour participer à des idées
nouvelles donc en un temps de travail
est un élément fondamental je ne vous
dis pas du tout que c'est la fin du
travail et je répète ils sont au chômage
en crève quinze mille morts à gauche
chaque année à cause du chômage là
maintenant il n'y a pas que le travail
d'un avis on a envie d'avoir du temps
pour soi donc je viens de temps
l'épanouissement par le travail
pour ces pacs c'est un peu datés
maintenant les politiques on parle
encore mais je me dis clairement que là
que le travail parce que souvent ce
qu'ils vous disent qu'ils vous parlent
que d'épanouissement par le travail
souvent ils ont un job passionnant alors
tous les seuls à tous les salariés n'ont
pas un job passionnant parmi eux chez
brioche pasquier un des trucs assez
étonnant c'est qu'il ya pas de machine
pour retourner les brioches quand ils
sortent du four elle tourne un peu donc
il ya des hommes et des femmes qui ont
le même cerveau que vous et moi et qui
sont en bout qui sont embauchés juste
pour remettre les brioches tout droit
c'est pas un job passionnant donc ils
sont contents d'avoir ce job parce que
ça leur permet de vivre d'avant un
salaire décent de parler avec d'autres
mais ils sont content aussi d'avoir du
temps pour vivre à côté donc je ne pense
pas que le travail soit le seul lieu
d'épanouissement possible
cagan oui moi je ne suis pas non plus un
suspect dans le vert sur le fétichisme
du travail c'est à dire je considère
comme bon nombre d'économistes libéraux
que le travail c'est le prix de la vie
tout simplement et que le but progrès
économique c'est de réduire ce prix vous
parliez du télétravail tout à l'heure je
me garderai bien de faire un commentaire
général là dessus parce que ça dépend
vraiment des préférences des uns et des
autres des contraintes des entreprises
on sait que pour beaucoup le bureau
c'est vraiment la seule manière d'être
productif là où le travail à la maison
est impossible et pour d'autres c'est
pas vraiment la même chose dont on ne
vit aussi je ne citais que ça en fait
que en télétravail on travaillerait plus
plus longtemps plus tard le soir oui
c'est une possibilité parce que c'est
vrai qu' il n'y a pas de la limite est
beaucoup plus floue entre la vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle et
donc on est tenté parfois de travailler
beaucoup plus maintenant c'est vrai que
moi je me méfie quand même de l'espèce
de 2,2 mode du télétravail qu'on a vu au
début de la pandémie en disant c'est
super enfin s'émanciper on va être
affranchi de la pression hiérarchique au
bureau en fait en son sens aperçoit que
cette pression hiérarchique ne disparaît
absolument pas la maison que les moyens
de contrôles sont juste différent or le
fait de ne pas pouvoir travailler au
bureau c'est aussi un générateur d'un
risque d'isolement social et donc moi je
suis je parierais sur le fait que cette
mode du télétravail la vie de s'estomper
et que les gens vont petit à petit
vouloir retourner au bureau le plus vite
possible
moi je suis pas devin je ne sais pas
vers où on va mais je pense
effectivement qu'on a tous besoin qu'un
d'être en lien avec d'autres travaillent
et pour réfléchir ensemble pour juste
pour le plaisir de prendre un café de
raconter nos vies au travail raconte ce
qu'on fait à l'extérieur et à
l'extérieur on raconte quant au travail
les engueulades où les où les succès
donc je pense pas qu'on puisse aller
vers le pour plein de raisons je pense
pas qu'on puisse aller vers le 100%
télétravail je pense qu'il a besoin de
présence et je crois qu'on est prêt pour
de nouvelles organisations des troubles
la réduction du temps de travail la
semaine de quatre jours par exemple
écologiquement c'est bon c'est pas bon
c'est plutôt bon n'ont pas souvent les
gens disent oui mais du coup on va
économiser sur les sur le transport en
fait c'est pas vrai parce que s'il ya
des salariés qui ont été embauchés
imaginez vous vous vaincre que quatre
jours il y aura un autre animateur moins
brillant mais qui sera un billet qui
très vite et voilà déjà d'ailleurs
plaint journalistes qui feront mais j'ai
aimé le truc les missions durent 4
mai donc ce qui vous dit que si on va au
boulot que quatre jours par semaine on
économise sur les transports oui
mélusine où les gens qui font des
brioches ou du jambon ou des logiciels
ne vont pas s'arrêter le jeudi soir donc
il ya d'autres salariés qui vont être
embauchés donc sur ce facteur dalles des
transports en commun ou les transports à
la voiture en tant que tel et kadio sont
neutres par contre on voit que des gens
qui sont passés à quatre jours au rythme
de vie plus cool plus l'eau on devait
faire plus de cuisine par eux mêmes
allez au marché faire de la cuisine au
lieu d'acheter des produits sur
transformé qui en bilan carbone qui ont
bilan pour notre santé et pour la
planète qui est moins bon donc ça
effectivement on voit que le bilan qui
est fait chez mamie nova pas mené par le
médecin du travail au bout de deux ans
est excellent on voit que l'absentéisme
a reculé que le stress au travail
diminue qu'on a enrichi le travail parce
que le patron de l' usine de le
directeur général épatez jeudi à
toulouse ils sont passés à quatre jours
donc il ya des choses qui ne font plus
qu'ils passent à leur numéro 2 le numéro
deux et qui est un cadre sup est lui
aussi pas sac à dos donc on embauche
quelqu'un là jusqu'aux ouvriers et un
jour par semaine ou le contremaître
n'est pas là et quand il ya carrefour où
les centres leclerc qui veulent les
yaourts on va pas dire appelé lundi
passe au vert donc ils comprennent à
améliorer la formation des ouvriers de
premier niveau qui peut qui ont un
boulot plus intéressant donc du coup on
se rend compte que l'absentéisme recul
vraiment ce qui est aussi bon pour les
salariés pour l'entreprise donc il y
avait donc ce qui m'énerve c'est qu'on
n'arrive jamais avoir un débat serein là
dessus je le répète en 95 le rapport est
déjà la demande de balladur il y avait
un consensus le rapport boissonnat il
faut réduire d'au moins de plus de 20%
le travail il dit bien juin 2015 pour ne
pas inquiéter les bourdes à la scala où
tout le monde était d'accord pour dire
qu'en 2015 évidemment c'est un mouvement
historique en 2015 évidemment on sera
tous passent à quatre jours je voyais un
l époque je vous ai invités bien sûr sur
canal+ assure josette l'argument qu'on
vous opposait contre la semaine de
quatre jours c'était qu' il allait
falloir et que comme on allait créer de
l'emploi il le faudrait augmenter les
surfaces des bureaux et augmenter le
nombre de places de parking ça c'est
faux c'est justement le mondial pas le
même grand tarbes du mort à l'époque non
mais c'est marrant c'est qu'on vous
écoute on ne m'en veuillez pas mais
alfred sauvy dans son histoire
économique de la france en même temps
critique les 40 heures avant le avant la
guerre pas ce n'était pas mieux mais dit
que les congés payés était une bonne
idée et dit que c'est quelque chose
d'étonnant c'est que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que tu réduire le
temps de travail d'un mouvement
historique et dit personne ne peut le
contester document dit oui évidemment
c'est un mouvement historique mais elle
n'est jamais bon moment parlant mal fait
on me dit ça n'est jamais le bon moment
quand il ya d'une croissance forte on
oublie un peu les chômeurs et quand une
activité qui a des problèmes on dit
attendez c'est pas le moment ce n'est
pas en travaillant moins qu'on va s'en
sortir donc alfred toby rig dit en riant
tout le monde est d'accord pour défier
d'un mouvement historique mais ce n'est
jamais le bon moment en 1906 et eu des
manifs où il y avait les curés et la cgt
qui étaient dans la rue pour dire on
veut un dimanche pour se reposer c'était
pas tous d'accord pour savoir si frais
le dimanche matin les les cathos et la
société n'allait pas tous mais là mais
il a fallu imposer dans la rue une loi
même pour obtenir le jour de repos le
dimanche en 1936 léon blum pensé que
c'était de la blague léon blum n'a
jamais parlé des congés payés avant
d'arriver au pouvoir et c'est le peuple
qui étaient dans la rue qui lui a imposé
les congés payés et finalement léon blum
a accepté et on est bien content que ça
et ça s'est plutôt bien passé et
maintenant le secteur du tourisme est le
premier secteur d'activité j'étais que
le virus va se faire oublier c'est le
nommé soin d'écouter le patronat de
l'époque qui dit que les vacances
étaient la connerie il est élu ouvriers
vont partir au bord de la mer et ne
reviendront pas toujours cette vision un
peu stupide et ouvriers j'en avais bay
aurait pas de congés payés ce serait
qu'à moins en moins cool je crois qu'on
est tous les trois contents d'avoir une
quelques vacances pendant l'été et en
termes d'activité les causes et les
effets c'est à dire que vous imputer à
la législation encore une fois où il y
avait les congés payés vous a pas le
deleware imputé à la législation
une dynamique qui est propre et internes
au capitalisme s'abstenir midam alors je
gérais j'ai rien compris donc le premier
mais y'a pas des gens qui sont fait tuer
pour réduire le temps de travail via une
loi non gabriel aubry a demandé je suis
venu mais j'apprends qu'il ya pas eu de
loi sur les courts j'ai payé japon qui a
parfois vous demande monsieur c'est que
je suis venu d'être venu je suis venue
des mesures sans l'avouer nuit ce que je
vous dis c'est que si ces lois n'étaient
pas devenus la croissance économique
aurait abouti à des résultats plus ou
moins comparé à lukla gobelins patience
il vaut bien barrio de la boum mais
aujourd'hui je voudrais je suis premier
avec vous a déploré le fait que nous
connaissons une croissance économique
atone mais dans les terrines imputerait
pas cette réalité aux mêmes facteurs que
vous simplement ce que je veux dire
c'est que encore une fois cette tendance
nude du temps de travail de la réduction
ton travail tu penses qu'il n'est pas
française qui est universel et qui a
lieu indépendamment des agents d'al
législatif à son petit nom sur la
réduction du temps de travail
aujourd'hui si vous regardez à l'échelle
de notre existence
donc si on enlève nos études notre
retraite nos vacances et notre temps de
sommeil on ne travaille plus que 10% de
notre vie c'est pour ça que c'est
étonnant que moi en ce moment oui oui
mais encore une fois vous frédéric vous
avez un job intéressant et chaque jour
vous êtes un débat intéressant vous êtes
du travail qu'on y est bah oui non mais
le travail reste quand même un élément
important pour vous il n'y a pas que ça
dans votre vie et moi là je suis député
va la canche arrivé on m'a demandé ce
que c'est intéressant de job de député à
bruxelles et c'est vraiment intéressant
y a pas que ça dans ma vie mais oui
c'est important pour nous pour se
construire et le revenu donc c'est juste
juste ridicule dans vingt ans les gens
diront ils ont été débile ils auraient
tous pu passer à 4 jours vivre bien que
ce qu'est un job à les garder leur job
et simplement en limite le risque de
burn out on leur demandait même pas de
baisser les salaires dans vingt ans les
gens osent dire mais pourquoi c'était si
compliqué donc un calcul comme je lé
fais c'est le sociologue jean viard 80
quelques la haie et qu'on se dit que mon
on ne travaille plus que 10% de notre
existence c'est à dire que nos aïeux
c'est beaucoup plus d'un aujourd'hui on
travaille plus en moyenne que 10 puis il
faut le saluer et c'est on dit que c'est
déjà c'est très bien ça c'est aussi
le rappelle qu'il faut faire des
croissants à tous ceux qui conspuent la
civilisation industrielle et
productiviste c'est le productivisme qui
nous a acheté cette société du temps de
loisirs et donc si demain effectivement
on met fin à la situation industrielle
et qu'on revient à une société de los
teques ça va être aussi été beaucoup
plus pénible que celles qui disent
aujourd'hui les chercheurs sayyari
travail étroit qu'il ait tué leur enfant
a entre autres qu'un dessin 20% de leurs
enfants qui quittent tu es donc c'est
pas non plus pour moi un modèle repose
toi relevé tuer les enfants non mais
bien sûr mais les vôtres
c'est de là à dire que les écolos
veulent
en revanche vous avez effectivement chez
les écolos une forme de contradiction
parce que quelqu'un qu'on de rigueur
c'est un grand théoricien la
décroissance vous dit effectivement
qu'il veut une société du temps libéré
en même temps conspuent le productivisme
qui a permis justement à cette société
du temps libéré d'advenir donc est là
une contradiction je crois qui est
insoluble mais le productivisme barre
dans ses pas le choix d'aujourd'hui mais
le monde est très sexy c'est les rois
d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas exactement parce
que la règle soit on travaille et il dit
au développement du productivisme et
elle ce site industriel m'écouter le
produit est encore une fois par des
agriculteurs sont très content qu'on ait
fait des gains de productivité
aujourd'hui avec juste 3 % de la
population qui est agriculteur on arrivé
n'aurait tout le monde et en même temps
les mêmes d'agriculteurs vous disent
qu'ils sont quand même inquiet de
bouffer le nombre de phytosanitaires le
nombre de cancers chez les agriculteurs
qui augmente dans leur vie dans leur
village et donc sur des aides en gardant
un bon niveau de production sont les
aides en quelques années à l'hiver et
culture william and produits chimiques
c'est meilleur pour leur santé c'est
meilleur pour la planète donc on peut
avoir un haut niveau de production sans
un productivisme qui fournit à la santé
des paysans et notre santé et les ter
donc on peut avoir un débat un peu plus
subtile sur ce qui est le productivisme
mais alors que le leur pour finir il
nous reste trois minutes trente le temps
de travail en soi est ce que ça n'est
pas un concept qui a est ce que c'est un
concept qui a encore de l'avenir havrais
d'eau de raisonner le travail en terme
de temps à vrai dire je ne sais pas
combien de temps je travaille pendant il
ya quand même des choses vous avez
raison pas j'imagine que cambrai fils à
une émission si vous avez
d'abord vous être une profession
intellectuelle qui à avoir une grande
liberté mais la quête des jours vous
mettez un costume je sais pas
pardon moi y'a des jours une type en
costume mais par contre quand je vais au
parlement européen où quand je viens
faire une émission de débat voilà donc
je crois quand même que pour la plupart
d'entre nous on sait les jours on va au
boulot et les jours on n'y va pas et
c'est pour ça qu'on est organisée
c'était pour ça qu on en revient au fait
que c'est le nombre de jours qui compte
et pas de nombre d'heures je répète
antoine riboud en 93 il faut dit il faut
passer à 4 jours 32 eur 101 étape
intermédiaire non pour ceux et celles
qui comptent leurs heures c 32 heures
mais ce qui compte c'est que c'est le
nombre de jours qui diminue et quel que
soit notre métier on c'est en gros le
nombre de jours on va au boulot et le
nombre et le jour où on n'y va pas très
bien ce que vous dites là parce que 4
eur 20,84 jours 24h sur 24 c'est pas
trop pourquoi cessé jeudi pour ceux qui
comptent leurs heures c'est bien du 32
heures mais un journaliste ne compte pas
forcément ses heures moi j'étais
consultant avant ont facturé les jours
d'ailleurs l'unité pour facturer un
avocat ou un consultant c'est les jours
où c'est les heures donc le travail un
informaticien il fait des jours quand
vous demandez à changer le système
informatique de votre entreprise on me
dit que ça va être 150 10 heures de
travail sans doute radicaliser à l'avant
c'est normal parce que vous avez déjà un
jour et des heures qui sont défiants
juste je te la question du travail ont
encore une fois ça n'est pas la fin du
travail je le répète ce n'est pas lui on
va pas vivre sans travail c'est une
utopie les carottes ne pousse pas tout
seul il y avait un agriculteur qui se
lèvent le matin le on a besoin de
travail mais globalement on produit
beaucoup plus avec moins de travail
c'est une bonne nouvelle si on est
capable de mieux le répartir tout au
long d'un canal vie rime pour c'est que
le temps de travail c'est un concept qui
perdurera oui je pense que ça ça a perdu
de sa va perdurer même si il faudrait à
mon ami l'associer avec la quantité
d'efforts c'est à dire que tous les
traders ne se ne se valent pas
effectivement une heure de travail de
fiscalistes n'a pas le même pénibilité
une heure de travail ouvrier dans une
usine bon et c'est vrai qu'encore une
fois l'intérêt de notre système
industriel c'est que non seulement on
réduit effectivement le temps de travail
mais aussi la pénibilité des tâches
nécessaires à la satisfaction de nos
besoins essayé aussi cet indicateur là
qu'il faut regarder même s'il est
beaucoup plus difficile de quantifier
évidemment la pénibilité c'est vrai que
la pénibilité pas la même pour tout le
monde mais il faut que beaucoup de gens
quel que soit leur métier aspire en même
temps par un vrai job et avoir du temps
libre dans libération la semaine
dernière ils ont fait la une sur la
semaine de quatre jours il y avait un
paquet très intéressant sur ldlc c'est
une entreprise d'informatique où tout le
monde aussi bien le patron que les gens
qui font la logistique lamballe votre un
ordinateur que ce qui fonde la hotline
ils ont huit cents salariés dans tous
les métiers à être passés à quatre jours
certains armes étaient pénibles et pas
très créative d'autres métiers plutôt
sympa mais tous idée très heureux de
passer à quatre jours je remercie tous
les deux devant participer
ce débat je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis et je vous donne rendez-vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
ans